hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play limbo the other wall
ah that was bad I'll bet how's that no
bad news buddy oh no don't you is the
world turning upside down what's happen
ah Maloney yeah yes
yeah maybe the spark should have been
tailed now
krile yellow that is great again Oh
rocks scuba
I'm off to get on the Fox
what get on it get on it get on it there
we go ride to Bob
Oh leap epic Oh
Shah at parkour okay now whoo definitely
out of the forest then I look for for a
long time
I'll please more enemies like that
spider up more more more of this because
this makes sense in the world
oh that box is gonna crush me huh ah try
to kill me come here I bushu a [ __ ] so
far we don't I will be over here
ah no bye why why how was how was I to
know about that it besides seeing the
rock there how was I to know how was I
supposed to know that
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah I'm sweet I know where I'm
supposed to be able to do we're gonna go
up here no I'm not that's not right
aren't they I can
oh there's no way I know
ah one down one to the head that's
hardly fair if I go backwards huh oh no
run leap nope is totally not it maybe if
I ride this rock I'm a brad this rock
yeah professional rock rider oh no
there's bad it's bad it's very bad
that's probably double extra mega ungood
get on that then leap and then ah maybe
that was it maybe that was it but now
I'm dead so it don't matter but maybe
that was a maybe he maybe maybe maybe
that was that maybe that was it maybe
that was it hope hope maybe that was it
get get over there get I said get over
there
I bish you now I get on you know when it
starts to slide I ride you that use the
momentum to leap up slide slide why
didn't it slide it pleaded before I'm
silly this is being okay now ah I push
you up the hill I'm so strong
okay I push you and then you start
sliding no you start sliding and then I
there we go
I real there we go here we go almost
there ah come on
what the hell box okay I just got put
there
I see you out there I see you judging me
harshly okay Boosh you a boo shoe okay
and then you're right there and then I
Wow
and I get up and then all
I know delete a butterfly did you know
that the original name for butterflies
was flutter buys because that's what
they did they fluttered by
oh hello who are you ah not a brainslug
not a brainslug troll brains luck ah no
don't kill me okay good good I don't
mean yeah where am I going
are we going where we go now where we
going now okay back back we go we go
back to the south back is good Blackie's
good big horn hey this isn't the same
something changed
huh get in
grew up know this bad that was bad that
was bad
oh come on never was a family
oh I see no wait I can't
hang on here and then go yeah there we
got area go go go go go jump
alright go and then let them eat my
brainslug here I'll be Goldman there we
go
alright boy fect now I just gotta get
back
this is a secret up there
is there or maybe that was maybe this
was the way out and that was the secret
oh oh gosh what do i do what do I do
I'm gonna go that way there's a ladder
up there too
find a secret
ah all right fine screw you time it
right
fine I'll go this way up up up up up huh
up up up up up up up oh yeah yeah we are
oh that must have been the other way
that was totally ha I got I got an iota
ha wait a minute
take that's not right
yeah then I time it I got time it yeah I
got oh that's so good oh that was so an
awful oh I'm so smart
yeah Oh got it
what the hell does this dude help me
what good was that ah what's not
electrified anymore what was the point
of that I'm confused
I get to go to mine car ride okay I need
the ladder over there somehow
now backwards to the conclusion the
other way moosh and now you go up
do anything at all oh I get it
I'm up there Oh okey-dokey
ah damn you damn you damn you ready
ready ready
ha I'm pretty [ __ ] jump whatever ok now
no no no no no no no yeah
ah damn you I did damn you you son of a
[ __ ] yeah watch stop jumping ah there
we go okay I know I could buy booze you
then I jump on you now I'm ready I'm
ready
I'm so ready
okay try this the other way maybe my
rotating dot
written account it's not gonna work
either
yes
ah ah Harry okay and then I bruise you
and then I jump on us and then you go
you go you go you freakin go ah I'm not
I must be doing this wrong
must be doing it must be must be doing
it wrong let me think here hmm I
[ __ ] I push it one way I tried to
get up that way and it doesn't work now
I push it the other way and try to pick
up and it doesn't work
[ __ ] both ways
what do I push it in both directions it
don't work
if no work
by the time it swings back it's already
down and I can't get there
about this oh wait yeah don't know why
that works footage kid so I'm happy yeah
oh you son of a [ __ ] yes [ __ ]
you son of a [ __ ] Umeda Foggia you ma
da
your madam your mother you mother I
swear I I break your knees
so I just got to do it twice that's what
I have to do
yeah
jump on its happen its apex of
perfection
oh yeah you're all those other failures
on the still the best Kurt song let's go
it's right oh I don't have much time for
a ride come on come on now come on
chime Oh
you can catch up
oh that's country I got I got oh come on
I'm eating on my time ah
Oh inside of theirs way to death not
scary not scary
oops ah you troll you son of a [ __ ] you
[ __ ] troll you [ __ ]
[ __ ] I swear okay I'm all out
of time for now thank you all so much
for watching and as always we'll see you
in the next part
bye bye